para estos migrantes los días previos al
fin del título 42 se dividen entre la
incertidumbre y la esperanza
cientos de ellos permanecen varados en
la frontera entre Estados Unidos y
México esperen que el fin de la polémica
a medida les permita cruzar hacia la
Unión Americana pero la situación podría
salirse de control según las autoridades
va a ser caótico durante un tiempo y
como planteé en la reunión Cuando
hablaron de recortes de no gastar dinero
qué demonios pasas y recortas vas a
recortar agentes en la frontera
necesitamos más en la frontera no menos
en la frontera
biden y su homólogo mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador hablaron Este
martes acordaron que ambos gobiernos
colaborarán en materia migratoria
las ciudades fronterizas ya están en
alerta la situación Aquí como ustedes
ven de más de mil personas fuera de la
parroquia y todos los albergues ya
llenos a reventar pues una situación de
crisis
no solo crisis migratoria sino crisis
humanitaria donde vemos que muchos de
nuestros hermanos y hermanas migrantes
Pues están quedando en la calle
durmiendo la intemperie con una sola
comida al día Muchas veces y dentro de
Estados Unidos la situación lleva
incluso a urbes lejanas a tomar medidas
hemos visto en las últimas dos semanas
un nuevo aumento de migrantes que llegan
a diario por eso hoy emitimos una
declaración de emergencia para responder
a la llegada de migrantes
las autoridades estadounidenses se
preparan para una llegada de hasta
10.000 migrantes por día a la frontera
sin embargo Washington ha anunciado
medidas como el despliegue de militares
para contener la crisis
[Música]